Two weeks prior to chemo, the protocol recommends phosphatidylcholine, which is body
biopic.
You see two capsules a day.
When do you recommend to stop taking this?
The day of chemotherapy?
Well, actually, you can take, technically, you can still take phosphatidylcholine right
through chemotherapy.
The purpose of taking phosphatidylcholine is that's the precursor for bio.
It will help bile production.
Phosphatidylcholine is also what is all your cell membranes.
It's a nutrient that all your cell membranes use to make the cells in the cell membrane.
It's good for brain function, but biggest reason why we recommend it is for the detox pathway
to help make bile.
Really, you can take that through chemotherapy that's not an antioxidant, so it's not
something you have to discontinue.
Day before chemo, the protocol says no son has no antioxidants.
Correct.
Are coffee enemas okay the day before?
Yes.
You can.
Technically, you could do coffee enemas throughout the whole time, too.
They're not functioning as an antioxidant, they're just helping with detoxification, but you
want to be on the real safe side just 48 hours after you do the chemo that I would just